[Music]
are we blades in that one for the love
of snipes how many times do i have to
say it
keep it singular there's only one blade
also show never gives us the context for
any of this
if it does it in another episode fine
i'll give back like 30 sins but for now
i'm all horned up for the alternate gem
dimension and the show keeps rolling
over insisting it has a headache
hello morty gets cell phone reception in
space meanwhile i lose connection any
time nearby squirrel farts
don't ask me how i know i just know okay
painting your toenails on your bed with
no towel or any kind of protection
underneath
yeah that's a great point the 3d
holographic warning system however is
operating at full capacity
i'd appreciate the detail in this call
screen except that your screen darkens
when you have it next to your face so
there's really no reason for it to be
showing anyway
look at all that work you did for
nothing rick and morty do you feel
ashamed
come on come on this works oh you
touched the ocean morty
technically the ship is touching the
ocean rick and morty are still in said
ships so
i don't see how the treaty we're about
to find out about with mr nemes has been
broken
kaboom you've been lawyered now face the
wrath of your once and eternal foe
mr nimbus sorry who is that
my nemesis nimbus nemesis never name
noted nor noticed until now noteworthy
nemesis named nonstop normally
this nimbus nimrod not nearly known
enough for nemesis nomination
i am mr nimbus he's gonna say that a lot
i mean i would too if that was my name
it's mr nimbus it's a lot better than
namor
uses magic ray to double the length of
the table but has to use a cloth to
clean up the wine spill
sure why not is that his nemesis rick
has a nemesis
rick and morty is clearly poking fun at
shows that introduce some random pivotal
character in a later season
such as cousin oliver and the brady
bunch or eli scruggs on desperate
housewives but rick and morty is only so
good at poking fun at these tropes
because they're too guilty of using
these tropes it's the classic comedy
trope-a-dope and we ain't falling for it
rick and morty
summer is gonna dive into the marianas
trench to recover the forbidden shell
that gives him his power
allowing your granddaughter to dive into
the marianas trench to recover the
forbidden shell that gives mr nemesis
power without her parents explicit
consent
so time moves faster in there it's like
a narnia thing i'm not a beaver who
believes in jesus christ
morty i think they call them bell
beavers they're a distant cousin to the
beliebers
it's a long story also he didn't ask if
you were a narnian just if it was like
narnia in there
i don't know man all that defensiveness
probably means you want to believe in
jesus
or be a beaver it's probably the beaver
thing mr nimbus is an ice cold
killer morty i'm pretty sure morty
already experienced the ice cold
killer sensation a few minutes ago when
jerry and beth declared their love of
porn to him
police a strange horny ocean man is on
my lawn
horny because he wears a speedo likes to
moisturize moves sensually
just cause he's sexy doesn't make him
horny jerry project much
fight
flee geez nimbus sums up the entirety of
the human relationship cycle in five
seconds
i don't know whether to take a sin off
for the intense but hilarious depth or
sobbing the corner contemplating the
mundanity of my existence
in other words yeah it's a rick and
morty episode leaving the recliner chair
reclined
patricide fine whatever terms term
number one how does nimitz not hear this
he's right across the table i
accidentally had a video playing with
similar noises across the table one time
and now i'm disinvited from family
thanksgiving
also where is this camera exactly and
did rick plant it and if rick did plant
it why didn't he just grab the forbidden
shell while he was down there
i thought you already went i did i just
just got a little busy
why would you make up a lie that makes
you look bad when the truth would make
more sense and take the blame off of you
yeah i got it but the adults wanted all
of it bing bang boom time to suck face
where is your wine boy richard i thirst
he's getting it i'm not sure why rick
thinks this because he didn't ask morty
to get more wine
what if it gets weird even just
contemplating having sex with a fish guy
already puts this in the weird category
so you might as well just go all in at
this point jerry
the wine survives this centuries of this
isn't every end a beginning stay back i
don't want your stripped-down sundance
sci-fi
oh rick and morty how i hath missed you
take your sin back from just being you
old friend
can you believe he bought that easier
than i can believe they've been running
the simulation non-stop all these years
just waiting on morty to return
but sure yeah go for it make a slightly
more wet title of
my sex tape i just took some wine i said
i was sorry what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you people
but it was morty's wine to take so why
does he think that that's the issue here
he realizes he's killed a lot of their
people right
uh it is morty though so i guess maybe
he doesn't realize this
frozen in time forever asleep in exactly
how long has forever been again morty
leaves one time and comes back a decade
later but another time it seems
millennia have passed
if you think i'm not gonna send your
inconsistent portal time passage rules
just because you didn't officially
establish any
you have severely underestimated my
willingness to stretch for a sin
why did i clone myself genitals weird
hoovy clone guy would be excellent at tv
sins
let me deus ex machina let's go home i
believe you mean deus ex
ricona you're gonna try to be all
excellent at tv sins and such at least
throw a portmanteau in there to pretend
to keep it fresh
oh sh that's cool why because it has a
setting that disintegrates all clothing
except the parts covering the genitals
i'd go with convenient
or prudish bruvenian did you think i
would let you die alone richard
ah pelvis ex junkana see that's how it's
done
yes time i had nothing but
time but
while rick wins is in pain at this nut
shot i feel the need to point out that
he's been standing here nonchalantly
ignoring chunks of flesh out of his body
either you feel pain or you don't rick
you can't have it both ways
pressing my third nipple opens the
delivery entrance to the magical land of
narnia
i'm i'm scared morty i can see the end
cold i'm cold i'm so cold
actually your father and i have been
very sex-positive lately
we've been watching pornography hey man
got a big box of corn for you
[Music]
is that mr nimmus nimbus i hear you can
talk to fish
right there sugarhoof i'm moving a
little slow tonight i had a hot pocket
for dinner
you will be the one to end our pain to
the pay